[Music]
and in the woods news submitted by shy
babe Nicole hookers aim before year-old
boy was found alive after being lost in
the woods for four days oh how did they
stay alive Stan enough three years old
for that just goes to show you can't
delicate the [ __ ] out of kids I'm not
feeding my kids for days I'm sure I
probably eat somebody else mother what
did the kid survive on he survived on
swamp water oh my god is he not dead
he ate grass this was [ __ ] hilarious
he's gonna do that at that age and where
did he sleep I'm surprised you didn't
get like a bacterial infection like that
up from the swamp water yeah cuz that's
stagnant water that's gross dirty yeah
dirty or parasite would you survive on I
ain't no god kid are you alive
that's basically he's eating those swamp
waters but grass makes you [ __ ]
diarrhea and throw up like that's why
dogs chew on grass I want to see you
like voice and animated kid okay I would
love that
somebody please hired me for that yeah
so this takes place in Prussia oh it's a
Russian K that's why yeah Russian kids
are so resilient yeah for the babes in
the wood simple weekend getaway this is
guys a Russian weightlifter and he's
pretty much saying like there's a lot of
people that ask him well what do you
think makes Russian weightlifting so
different neo as well first of all
starting when I was a baby my dad used
to make me jump outside in the ice-cold
water every single morning so that's my
morning routine starting when I was a
kid because there was just no and
there's like a lake you know so because
of that my mental toughness is already
this much above Americans so he's like
so if that's my starting baseline now I
can do this many more things but
Americans are a lot of other countries
that without that mental toughness or
started behind me I must be a common
thing since I was two I mean I know it's
a TV show but I saw a TV show that the
little girl like her dad made her do the
same thing too like when it was snowing
and like there was ice everywhere and
make him jump into
I didn't write well that's why Russians
are so gangster but you know what we
still make more money than them so it's
cool to be lazy I'm cool with being a
lazy American very specifically when I
was in elementary school you know you
get to like your little scuffle is [ __ ]
and kids would hit you it wouldn't hurt
as much because my parents would whup my
ass ten times harder right cuz they
would hit you with bat sticks and when a
kid comes up with these swings that she
was kind of like hey this is not so bad
you know ya know this kid name is Dima
we don't have snow here so I don't care
Dima that's such a Russian name Dimas
family they were all camping and during
the day that he went missing he went
with his dad about 165 feet away from
the camping site to go chop up some wood
and so the dad was saying that Dima
didn't want to be there anymore so then
he sent him back to his mom and so he
was saying it was just a straight shot
like he'd never thought that he would
stray away from that he saw a butterfly
and he started chasing it I think yeah
so then the dad after he found out that
this kid never made it to the campsite
he was just so devastated all the police
everyone was involved there were so many
people involved in trying to find this
little boy for days like it was all over
Russian media - I feel like as each day
goes by you're kind of accepting that
your baby's dead yeah I probably set
that up to the second day maybe if
you're a Russian parent you're like he's
still alive no no it's like three months
later then they're like he's probably
not about half year then he still alive
somewhere yeah yeah and so I contacted
the police there was there was just a
search team going on and they were even
investigating the parents they had them
do a lie detector test to make sure that
they were like foul play there so back
we're sliding tickets just don't do she
doesn't show [ __ ] especially if you're
nervous human being is just gonna be all
over the place all the time
I had homies that shank people and sold
drugs and did coke and they're cops now
so doesn't like do anything yeah doesn't
do [ __ ] cuz when you want to be a cop
that's why you have to take a polygraph
test and so you can pass it like if
you're a good criminal you just passed
it there you have good nerves and no
emotions this is that's so crazy the
media as well they were questioning the
parents
motives [ __ ] the media parenting skills
yeah all of that so this little boy was
missing for four days on the third day
they decided that you know this kid
there's no way he would have found in
that direction let's go in this
direction but then they're saying that
those is one man ahead of one of the
team's I was like no I got this gut
feeling we should go in this other
direction than you guys don't think we
should go
what's the gut feeling I see these
little footsteps no yeah and they were
also like tracking us but steps too so
they got [ __ ] dogs or some [ __ ] that
can go on smell yeah I'm sure they were
using everything so they were finally
going down that path and within the hour
they found the little boy thank you this
one dude he was doing pull-ups on a
branch no he said he had a video cut
bill instead of fire started oh this is
too [ __ ] for me we had a rabbit skin
rabbits [ __ ] on the rotisserie yeah I
feel so terrible
like how mine is going like when you
told me it's like you know who said
don't they have dogs that we funded they
sent a dog to find out the dog finds the
kid but he mauled him in the brought him
back to him oh wow that's wrong God they
got the wrong dog that was not like
military attack dog yeah instead of like
the search-and-rescue dog for some
reason I gave you the benefit of the
thought that the doubt and I thought
that the kid mauled the dog because the
kids so gangster oh you went too dark on
the mo sorry I know I thought you were
going there too no he got killed by the
dog the guy that ended up finding him
said that he came across a root of a
fallen tree and then he looked inside
and that's where he saw a little boy
more a little wow what a smart kid
and so what they did is that they stole
a whole tree instead of like the
rescuers they created a stretcher out of
clothes and so they need like they
carried him out and then they quickly
took them to a hospital did he need to
be carried out they just forced them I'm
not sure the kids are fine like I don't
want to let you know no this looks
better on camera and we carry only save
you and they were saying that there is
scrambling to try to get a helicopter
but the ended I'm just taking on you
know Alec
ambulance and then so once the kid got
to the hospital they're saying that he
was in moderately serious condition
whoo and that's he was dehydrated
sunburned suffer suffering from
hypothermia he has a better seat 20 tick
bite oh [ __ ] a mosquito bite and that
the insects themselves had been sent out
to the lab to determine like if there
was any Y disease or [ __ ] and then
they're saying that he received a shot
of antibodies as a precaution and water
he was drinking yeah and that it's
really hard to tell how the situation
will develop but I just know that this
kid to me toughest [ __ ] now he's gonna
be like a Russian [ __ ]
special-operations look like a grown-ass
man in your face that's a four year old
I know look like you six yeah when I
think four year old I think like a
skinny little I mean a short little
chubby toddler he looks older than Isaac
he does yeah those Russian genes gonna
do the same [ __ ] to your kid like the
Russian guy would you're asking he
doesn't have a kid oh I'm sorry are you
gonna do the same thing to to your kid
like put him through like harsh
environments to toughen him up to get
his mental fortitude above what the
regular standard is I don't even know
what that means I think I would but not
in the Russian way where it's like
because the Russian way is kinda like
the Asian way yeah I think I would try
to want to make it fun where I would
where the kid would enjoy jumping into
ice-cold yeah yeah I would try to lead
by example make it into a fun challenge
like it's a JK party if I jumped that
and he jumped in he likes it or if I
take martial arts he takes one you're
like yeah you're strong and I slowly
like push him and then he gets tougher
and tougher I don't want to like just
force him the way Asian pears do no I
was thinking about just waking him up
with a punch of the stomach there's no
difference yeah I mean I'm I'd be a mom
so like I don't think I'm like very
prissy so I don't think I'd have a
pretty kid but no I feel like I'd agree
until I hear the baby cry
and I'm like [ __ ] that's so [ __ ]
annoying just shut them up and like give
them a cookie kids I need ya cuz I don't
want to hear the crying that just keeps
going and going and going and I'm like
dude trying to listen to my [ __ ] Bob
Marley right now but you're ruining the
[ __ ] vibes [ __ ] yeah maybe it's good
you don't have kids yet you're not ready
in due time
shut up baby well you want a cookie all
right here take it the baby's gonna cry
if you put him in snow I you see your
baby like paperclip is the name I feel
like your child is gonna be in this
equipment when you look into the crib
adjust all cookie crumbs and [ __ ] toy
yeah whatever it takes to let them play
this kid is so tough cuz they're saying
that when they found him he was cold and
wet and all his clothes were torn the
part that I couldn't really believe is
how he has sunburn and his hypothermia
no they suspect that he has pneumonia as
well maybe cuz it gets hella cold at
night and hella hot in the daytime yeah
it might be like that kind of weather
but what kind of people play in the rain
forest though is that like just a
recreational Russian thing no he was
just camping okay I look at the pictures
in rain forest remember that little
Japanese boy that they left and then
they're like well daddy mommy's gonna
drive away and you're like [ __ ] you then
and then he went into the forest and you
survived oh yeah
the same [ __ ] some of these kids they're
just meant to survive that's sure they
don't they don't they don't do articles
on the kids and the dying on the ones
that survived yeah
the one that died like duh yeah so
they're saying there were about 2,000
people looking for him that's cool
outfits I like the little hat that's so
crazy dude like the woods they can eat
you alive
Owen experience real camping just one
and then I'm done what's real camping
like taking a [ __ ] outdoors and all of
that their own electronics I have to
hike up to the camping spot no car no
nothing I want to experience we talked
about Yosemite [ __ ] okay where you have
to dig a hole even doubt there's like
there's like subcategories are you
talking about you hunt for your own food
or you being you bring pre-packed food
no I would have to do prefect I can do
huh she's not my leg Yosemite hikes
where you have to go up you carry all
your stuff with you and when you have to
take a [ __ ] you're gonna dig a hole [ __ ]
in the [ __ ] hole hike somewhere set
up camp huh but you have prepared food
yes okay and prove like camping
equipment that [ __ ] his brother by I can
do it so it's like backpack
instead of like bushwhacking yeah that
sounds fun they're gonna make a fire
were sisters well I gotta go with
someone that actually knows the forest
you go there you just set up camp site
and it's like dude that's just a [ __ ]
skunk hole that you just set up next to
you wake up with skunk fart all over
your face and [ __ ] and there's like a
skunk orgy every night or some [ __ ]
sponsor she's [ __ ] ten skunks they
start [ __ ] each other they [ __ ]
squirt each other's gunk orgy happening
but did dust you though cuz I remember I
went camping one time with my family and
we were having a bathroom making s'mores
and now all send there's these two
skunks that come out one skunk went
directly into like this can of like
baking grease and just started drinking
it and then the mother skunk went into
like the bag of graham crackers and just
started like eating out of it and then
it like would turn it's like when we try
to approach these skunks like they would
turn their butts around us and lift up
their tail and we all just like ran away
favorite campsite like eventually like
the skunk that was drinking out of like
the the baking grease you know or didn't
die but like the can roll down and so it
went with it nice and then the graham
cracker ones it just like dragged the
ground Packer bags into the sewer her
food like sewer pipes they were like
what the animals the adapt watch out for
the skunks man hey guys thanks for
watching that last episode if you
haven't already make sure to hit that
subscribe button because we upload
videos every single day for you guys now
to watch more videos check them out up
here
[Music]